today for our daily cancellation we will
be canceling the pollsters at cbs
uh now the media and the left were
engaged in more of their customary
performative hysterics yesterday over
the results of a
recent cbs poll as a quick side note
here this is this is
yet another poll for which i was not
contacted i have never been contacted
about any poll or survey ever in my life
neither has anyone in my family or
anyone i've ever asked
do they just pull the same 600 people
where do they keep these
are they being held in a dungeon
somewhere or maybe like a robotic
womb a lot of the matrix but these are
questions for another day i suppose
um in any case this poll asked
respondents about the coronavirus
um i don't know how they would even know
about the virus from their matrix womb
but that again is beside the point
one of the questions was this is how it
was it was framed
the number of u.s deaths from the
chronovirus has been
and then the options are acceptable or
unacceptable
and as you can see 50 percent of
republicans said it was acceptable
while 90 of democrats bravely took a
stand and said
no no death is unacceptable entirely
unacceptable i will not accept it
and i guess this explains why i don't
get called for polls because
if they had asked me i would have said
option
c the poll question is unacceptable
because the poll question is
unacceptable because it's stupid and
incoherent and has absolutely no
function or purpose except to trap
republicans into saying
exactly what 57 of them did say
acceptable
what what the hell could that possibly
mean in this context to call something
acceptable is to say that
you accept it and to say that you accept
it is to say that you will allow it you
will tolerate it you will bear it
so what else could a death toll be other
than
acceptable phrased another way what
choice do i have but to accept it
1500 people died when the titanic sank
is that acceptable to me well
it's sad i don't like it i wish it
hadn't happened
but now that it has do i accept it i
suppose so what other choice do i have
if i say no i don't i don't you know no
i don't accept the titanic death toll
okay then
what does that mean what does that
amount to can i cause those lives to
regenerate by refusing to accept their
laws
will the ship emerge from the icy depths
fully intact because matt walsh has
announced that it's it's sinking was
simply unacceptable to him everything
that has happened in the past
is acceptable to you because it must be
it might also be horrible infuriating
outrageous tragic terrible a million
other things
but it must also be acceptable because
you have
literally no other option besides
begrudging
acceptance you know try conducting a
poll
on an airplane after both engines have
failed and it's plummeting to the earth
ask the parent the passengers if gravity
is acceptable to them
i'm sure a lot of them will say no but
sadly gravity will still be gravity and
they're still going to be going down
whether they accept it or not so
the dichotomy of acceptable versus
unacceptable is meaningless here
there's a reason why nobody ever pulls
you know to ask how many cancer deaths
are acceptable or diabetes deaths or
heart disease or car accidents
if they did you might think on one hand
no deaths are acceptable
death itself is unacceptable but on the
other if you possess even the slightest
capacity for honest self-reflection and
assessment
you will see that inevitabilities don't
care whether you accept them or not
now you could argue that what this
question is really trying to ask is
whether the respondent
respondents think the response to the
coronavirus
was acceptable whether more could have
been done whether steps could have been
taken to save some of those lives
whether the policies put in place were
effective or not etc but
those are not the questions that were
asked those questions
could have been asked have been asked
but this question is different this is
asking
whether you accept what has already
occurred
they might as well ask you whether you
accept that the color blue is not the
color red
you might say that i'm playing a game of
semantics here splitting hairs missing
the larger point but if you say that i
would say that it is you who is missing
the larger point because
the fact that the question makes no real
sense is
exactly the point it's why it was posed
in the first place
there is no right answer to a nonsense
question
and there could only be one reason why
pollsters would pose
a nonsense question it's because they
can frame the answer
however they want it becomes like some
sort of strange reverse
rorschach test type of thing but let's
pretend for a moment
that this question had been posed about
the future
rewind the clock back what if they'd
been asked whether 170
000 potential deaths in the future would
be acceptable
maybe if you want to be generous you'd
say that that's what the poll question
is getting at it's asking
if you could go back in time to before
the deaths occurred
would you consider 170 000 plus deaths
acceptable of course again
if that's what they meant to ask they
could have asked it but let's pretend
they did
would that make more sense no not at all
past deaths obviously can only be
acceptable to us because they are facts
and one can only accept facts or shut
his eyes and think happy thoughts
instead but
not a lot not lot not a lot of good that
does what about future deaths
those aren't facts yet can we talk about
acceptable versus unacceptable in that
context
no we can't or we can but it will be a
totally
arbitrary and meaningless conversation
170 000 deaths is a lot
you say it's unacceptable fine what
amount of death from the chronovirus
would have been acceptable to you and
how did you arrive at that figure
would you have insisted that zero people
are allowed to die from this
even one death is unacceptable okay but
was that ever an
option was there ever even a theoretical
possibility of
no one in america dying from the global
pandemic
probably not so what is your acceptable
figure
and how did you arrive at that number
let's pull something out of the blue
let's say 50
000. would that have been acceptable if
you say yes then i'd have to ask how you
know that 50
000 was ever in the cards ever possible
and whether it was or wasn't
50 000 is still a lot it sounds horrible
to say that 50 000 deaths are acceptable
just like it sounds horrible to say that
say that of 170 000 deaths or any amount
of death
there just is no way to ever attach the
word acceptable to death
any death in any number that won't sound
bizarre
callous and somewhat sociopathic that's
because again
acceptable versus unacceptable is a
meaningless dichotomy in this realm
and wherever we draw the line between
the two it will be unavoidably arbitrary
but i do think there's something deeper
going on here deeper than a dumb and
pointless question
our reaction to this pandemic to this
confrontation with a mortal threat
and thus a confrontation with the fact
of our own mortality
has revealed again that we are a culture
totally unwilling to accept the reality
of death or confront it in an
honest way in fact it turns out lots of
us really do think that not accepting
death is a viable
option which is why many people support
the idea of locking down
all of society and hiding in our homes
indefinitely economy be damned thousands
of small businesses be damned
personal liberty be damned constitution
be damned everything be damned
as long as we can avoid at all costs
any amount of physical risk we cannot
bring ourselves to face the fact
that this disease is out there that will
probably always be out there in some
form
and that people will die from it you
know that we can
and should take steps to mitigate the
risk to some extent but that society
still must function
and that as society functions people
will die
from this and a million other things we
can't face that because we're so
terrified of and overwhelmed by the very
idea of our own mortality you know we
will not say to ourselves i might die
and i accept that
and we mock anyone who does say it as
though they're suicidal nihilists when
in fact
those you know they're saying it are
only acknowledging
a fact that applies to us too no matter
what we do
because we cannot escape mortality any
more that we can escape the waves on the
ocean while we sail across it
another example of this feeble refusal
to accept the inevitable
um can be found in climate alarmism
alexandria quezo cortez this weekend
tweeted in response to the news that two
hurricanes
might strike the gulf coast at the same
time and she said talk to me again about
how a green new deal goes too far
to address the problem this is a woman
who really believes that a piece of
legislation
can stop hurricanes it's not an
exaggeration to say that climate
alarmists like her
think we can legislate hurricanes away
they believe we can raise our hands and
halt the winds and calm the seas like
gods
our utter powerlessness in the face of
these natural forces is too much for
them to accept
our smallness and finitude and
vulnerability against the scale of the
whole earth and cosmos
is so terrifying they try to reduce it
all down to a problem for bureaucrats in
dc to handle
they might as well hold a congressional
hearing to come up with a strategy to
stop our galaxy from colliding with
andromeda in five billion years
the refusal to face the inevitable and
the unstoppable
especially that most inevitable and
unstoppable of things mortality
has been a driving force for human
society since the birth of consciousness
but in our society in particular the
force is very strong
and never has that been more obvious
than right now
and that is why wait who was canceled at
the beginning of all this oh yeah
cbs pollsters are canceled
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated